ポケモントレーナーの背負うわしじゃ
ハァー機の果て者みんな元気にポケモンを捕まえて居る可能者がみんなが知っている
通り今のこの者がにはモンスターボールが無いのじゃ
つまりわれわれ人間はもしポケットモンスターで締めてポケモンに絶対
遭遇してしまったら間違いなく殺されてしまう
基本いい奴だジャガー野生のポケモンでで行ってしまうと話が別じゃよく考えてみ
なさい
我々人間がポケモンに感じるわけがない
ジャガーそんな我々でもポケモンを倒す方法がうわずかにある年たら
走行しっかりと覚えで
たいもんじゃのうというわけで今日はザラなモンスターノールがない
今我々人間がポケモンに出会ってしまったらどう対処すべきなのか教えていこうと
ウォンじゃあなーそういうわけで今日を乗せな日本もの倒し方教えてくれる奴が俺と
ハートしやー
よろしくたのんなのじゃもう
ハイアーキの葉加瀬ありがとうございますここからの担当は私ポケモントレーナー波戸
氏が担当しますよろしくお願いします
この公園は球技が禁止されていますので
モンスターボールの使用ができませんもしこういう場所で野生のポケモンとで行って
しまうと大変危険です
野生のポケモンは
やさしいポケモンばかりとは限りません突然人間と出会うことによって驚いてしまい
攻撃をしてくることがよくありますのでそんな時の対処法を今日は皆さんにおせようと
思いますあくまで護身用なので
あの自分の身を守るための方法に過ぎませんこの
方で必ず自分の身をポケモンからもうれるという保証はありませんのでご了承の方
よろしくお願い致します
かなりの確率でその野生のポケモン大きいです
または絶命に追い込むことができますのでその隙に
金造はポケモントレーナーまたは警察の方に連絡してください
それは見ていきましょうどうぞ
持ってからよ
[音楽]
あればトカゲポケモンの人影じゃあな炎タイプじゃぞ
連戦に考えると炎を深めるとマルコギザっ死んでしまうぞ
だがポケモンずかんにはこう書いてある生まれた時からシッポに歩道が灯っている
報道が消えた時その命は終わってしまう
簡単じゃのう人影の尻尾にめがけで
水をかけるのじゃっそうするとしトカゲは絶命してしまうとこれにて一件落着者
もっと続いてはビー玉じゃのう
このポケモン見た目は豆が油断してはならの大爆発して普通に死んでしまうぞ
なので簡単じゃビリー魂が大爆発するまでてリトバスのじゃなんとか死ぬことだけを
逃れられるんじゃなぁ
[音楽]
r
ほんと続いてのポケモンはコイキングじゃのう
魚こげもみずタイプのポケモンじゃただの恋に見えるが実際ば金が来て超強いと跳ねる
ですら危ないかもしれんぞ
コイキングの倒し方ちょっと時間がかかるかもしれんがこういったみずタイプの
ポケモンで見ての通り外でピチピチ跳ねておるのじゃ中でいっちゃいロチ
が放置しておくことによって乾燥させるのじゃそうすることによって干からびて飲酒
状態まで追い込むことができるのじゃ
これにて一件落着じゃのう
[音楽]
はあああ温度は続いての抗議文は a loud 者なんて人間だと消えるだけで
しまうしまうんじゃなあ俺は絶対絶命者と覚えたいところじゃが
正面からエアームドを見てみるんじゃこいつ正面に目がないんじゃなぁ
つまり3今このエアームドハート氏の位置がわかってないから
ゆっくりゆっくりとエアームドの視界に入らないように真っ正面に詰め寄ることによっ
てエアームドの近くまで家帰ることが可能なのじゃなぁ
そしてそのまま脳天チョップ一発で瀕死状態じゃじゃーん
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ